So as we said, understanding these 3 components of value proposition
work together with understanding the 3 components of customer segments.
And in value proposition, the goal of this is to find out that minimum viable product.
And in customer segments, the goal is to understand in detail
the customer archetype or persona.
And again, this equals product market fit.
I can't emphasize enough that the business model canvas is just a start.
It's great to strategize and think about who customer segments are
and value proposition and channel,
but remember all you're doing is writing down hypotheses.
Your job is to turn those hypotheses into facts.
And there are no facts inside your building.
So your job is to get outside and test them personally in a physical channel
by talking to hundreds of customers;
in a Web and mobile channel by talking to thousands virtually and some portion physically.
You need to watch people's pupils dilate when they actually see and like your product.